Here are the three equations. Great work if you found each of these. We'll
start by making this base be the base for our exponent. So 3 is written down
here. The answer of a logarithm is an exponent. So, we know this 2 is going to
be the exponent for our base 3. And this should make perfect sense since 3
squared equals 9. This is that number. For the second one, we'll repeat the
same process. The base of our logarithm is 5, so 5 will be the base for our
exponent. The answer of a logarithm is an exponent. So this 3 is the exponent
for our base of 5. And of course 5 to the third equals 125. And finally we'll
have a base of one fifth here, an exponent of negative 2 which equals 25.
Remember that this negative exponent will flip over or do the reciprocal of
this base. So, one fifth will become 5 and then we'll square it to get 25. Nice
work if you got each of these right. Even if you got two of them right,
fantastic.